welcome to this video playing freddy
matsu bra Freddie mas bra from Brazil
okay close the sealian group really
close whatever I really try to be quick
for once okay managed so far just
playing instantly right not wasting any
time on explanations just putting out
the moves funny right I can't do it in
normal blitz over the thought I play
much quicker when I don't don't do the
comments okay this is a this is a
well-known line with black giving up an
exchange in like night x and I texa give
up the exchange a deform already is a
mistake on white spot not a mistake in
terms of our white is worse but it's um
it's not a very very promising variation
yeah we see that in this in this
position black has lots of activity and
he has declined to take the exchange so
I'm going to keep it for the moment okay
so let's see this is um yeah I can just
go nitey to hear if I like and take on
p2 it's technically possible i think
just do that not spend much time on it
rook takes Queen d1 d1 Bishop e2 wins
and exchange so he has to go to h1 and
the next move I'm taking on b2 loop
so this should be at least a poem okay
grab here it takes with Eirik Knight c3
trades off night at least with good play
rook takes yeah I don't know I can also
just move the night back maybe to see
three relief it's got Knight f6 though
yeah if I rethought Knight c3 here would
be a good idea or not
96 maybe no that's it see this rook is
hanging first and foremost you can give
this check on the six but it doesn't
lead to much really Oh came here I can
just take this try to simplify look the
ADA rope the edge you can take a seven
maybe
some way to keep the material here yeah
like a five maybe 85 let's go g4 maybe
g4 and 96 coming it's not very nice oh
come on maybe maybe this one it looks we
get to protect a seven here if it takes
Knight X my night is at least activated
still have forgotten about this 96
possibility really really not good I can
click with the pond though yeah well
this is a good idea anyway this protects
my bishop and they have 93 and Bishop e6
coming see to us all of a sudden malukas
activated okay this wasn't this wasn't
planned but it's not bad
okay so nitey three maybe shouldn't be
too bad
and yeah I certainly I had a better
position at one point I mean better than
that in comparison i mean can i take it
does not look like i can take it wrong
look see one book see aid I think
yeah I'm keeping to be slightly head of
the clock at least okay and rooks eola
also have 93 which is not that great can
take an OT seven
okay probably here threatening Roxy one
with made might be might be helpful
yeah not not a very harmonious position
I can also give check first check here
check on everyone kingi to not leading
to much I can go here though d3 maybe d3
trying to push this through we should be
a take on it to and win well that looks
good
fancy move or no fancy move look
everyone maybe I can take okay so no
fancy more where do I go rope to c8
maybe when tending hook Seto yeah that
looks ok
okay still I could do this Roxy to with
the peace I guess at the end i will i
will promote at the end time warning
well i guess it should be enough see one
queen
Jack guide resigns yeah it felt good to
have some extra time on the clock okay
so we had a funny opening line here in
this position Black has some some choice
B 6 is a pretty interesting line one
line what idea is to get exactly what we
got in the game this kind of idea night
f5 is a little bit of a little bit of a
shocker it's not that bad for white but
very often claims victims because it
looks some yeah it is surprising and
this year is already a bit more
comfortable for black there's those
ideas like Bishop c4 as mentioned he
went here and the big idea is that here
okay I can also take with the porn but
even something like that if we just
imagine this position as fantastic am
like this and this so we went to this I
went to the g5 p.m. and yeah okay well
securing the rook cannot be countably
bad when T and then yellow this is just
winning material but I didn't really
played it so convincingly it seems what
is the computer giving him f6 with a
winning position minus 1.5 why is it so
bad and it just goes back now then
Knight c3 is maybe even stronger i am
now but bishops are of course terrible
for him if you look at this this Bishop
is our amazing covering tons of square
sound very good position
yeah this k in here yeah and this is
probably not not really f6 is just just
good again didn't see it and this is
it's okay few black but not not that
spectacular yeah still had more more
coordination in TM winning with the deep
on so it was always a bit better but I
didn't make the best out of it i guess
this b6 line is it's an interesting
alternative to this this is the old main
line and okay for black of course it is
believed that black should react to the
d4 threat somehow and b6 is an
interesting way to to counter that black
can even after default play Bishop a six
but I always like this as d5 it's very
tricky okay thanks for watching